[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était quand la dernière fois où vous
vous êtes senti libre vraiment libres 1
vous savez cette cette idée que les
contours de nos vies sont sans doute
beaucoup beaucoup plus vaste qu'on peut
l'imaginer
l'idée par exemple qu on a aussi tout le
temps devant soi pour faire les choses
c'est rare ça ou bien que notre corps
bouge librement l'idée de la liberté
quand où tout est possible
alors moi ça c'est un sujet qui m'a
toujours vraiment enthousiasmés et c'est
pour ça que je me suis installé dans un
monastère bouddhiste pendant 15 années
là bas j'ai beaucoup appris notamment
grâce au maître zen
olivier wang n et puis il faut il faudra
un peu geeks complet pour vous raconter
comment j'ai débarqué là bas tout ce qui
s'est passé
la vie dans un monastère c'est vraiment
très spécial mais aujourd'hui j'ai
surtout envie de prat de partager avec
vous trois enseignements clé trois
expériences très marquante qui m'ont
permis de trouver aujourd'hui une
certaine sérénité intérieure
le premier le premier enseignement j'ai
appelé le petit oiseau du soleil levant
ça c'est mon côté un peu poétique et
l'histoire se passe au japon où je me
suis lancé la tête la première dans l'
aventure d'une retraite traditionnelle
zen donc on est en 2008 j'ai atterri à
nagoya dans un monastère de nonnes
duquel selon la légende
toutes les personnes qui arrivent toutes
les normes occidentales qui arrivent là
repartent à peine arrivé en effet les
conditions de pratique sont très très
ascétique
il ya vraiment rien du confort moderne
n'a pas d'eau chaude
tout se passe à l'eau froide alors du
coup mes mains vont faire la découverte
de ce que c'est les crevasses et les
engelures
on est en plein hiver et ya pas de
chauffage une très grande promiscuité
aussi entre les personnes on a une
chambre comme ça de 10 mètres carrés
qu'on partage à six ou sept en fonction
des périodes d activité soutenue du
matin au soir
c'est pas n quant à un ses actes axa
avance dans tous les sens et puis tout
ça en langue japonaise
l'anc dont ma connaissance se résume à
peu près aux chevaliers du zodiaque
alors sur un peu paumé adam et puis le
but de tout ça de cet enseignement
traditionnel très précieux évidemment
c'est de nous pousser dans les limites
jusqu'au lâcher prise au bout de trois
semaines m'ont lâché prise à moi c'est
que j'en ai ras-le-bol j'ai tenu trois
semaines quand même au bout de trois
semaines j'en ai ras-le-bol
c'est trop et un matin dans ce monastère
là-bas tout seul sans contact avec
l'europe rien je décide de partir et ce
jour là à l'intérieur de moi c'est un
peu ouais une immense déception
j'ai mis tellement tellement de d'espoir
dans ce voyage est celui-là vraiment
avec le la boule au ventre je rassemble
mes affaires dans la chambre il ya plus
personne je suis tout seul et à un
moment donné je lève la tête comme ça et
par la fenêtre je vois comme ça juste
derrière la fenêtre il ya une branche
avec de la neige et dessus un petit
oiseau et il est tellement délicat il
est tellement beau il est l'âme sa vie
il se secoue un peu comme sa police et
ses plumes et moi à ce moment là
l'émotion de ressentiments entre
déception et laisse la place à 2
l'émerveillement devant la splendeur une
grande tendresse comme ça qui surgit des
profondeurs
et si c'était ça l'enseignement que
j'étais allé chercher à dix mille
kilomètres les émotions et les pensées
en général sont un permanente
ça veut dire qu'elles apparaissent et
qu'elles peuvent aussi disparaître un
instant c'est la colère l'instant
d'après c'est l'émerveillement devant la
splendeur du monde et je pense qu'on a
tous fait cette expérience chacun dans
nos vies quotidiennes
par exemple au boulot où il ya un
collègue qui nous énerve on a des
conflits des trucs qui se passent pas
bien on ressasse et caetera et puis un
coup de fil d'un ami qui raconte une
blague qui nous raconte un truc marrant
et tout d'un coup on éclate de rire il
ya cette capacité à l'intérieur de nous
ça c'est le premier enseignement les
émotions sont un permanente et c'est un
petit oiseau qui me l'a dit le deuxième
enseignement alors celui-là il est un
peu différent encore que mais je les
appelais il ya quoi dans ma tête je vais
pas tout vous dire un moment y'a quoi
dans ma tête c'est en fait cette idée
que pour pour que les émotions soit 1
permanente c'est-à-dire qu'elles
apparaissent et qu'elle disparaisse ok
ça c'est bien mais il faut pas les
ressasser
en général on a plutôt tendance à
boucler quoi il ya un truc qui se passe
ça nous plaît pas et puis ont remis non
on a tous fonctionnement un peu
naturelle à l'intérieur de nous et pour
pouvoir arrêter de ruminer c'est
vraiment très important de comprendre et
de réaliser qu'on est en train de le
faire donc de mieux comme être mieux
connaître mieux savoir ce qu'on a dans
la tête
y'a quoi dans ma tête alors ça j'ai fait
l'expérience aussi une fois j'étais
assez dans méditation en mode bouddha
paisible
je n'aurais pas pu faire je crois alors
mots de bouddha fusible et à ce moment
là le maître dit laissez passer vos
pensées et vos émotions comme des petits
nuages dans le ciel
c'était beau et ça m'a mis dans une rage
terrible parce que moi mes émotions et
mes pensées à ce moment là c'était pas
des petits nuages paisible et vaporeux
dans un ciel azur et c'était plutôt des
gros cumulonimbus bien noir bien compact
et qui avait tendance à stagner donc en
apparence bout d'un paisible à
l'intérieur ça bouillonnait alors comme
vous pouvez vous en rendre compte
j'étais super motivés pour réussir à
faire ça donc j'ai beaucoup étudié et
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de vous faire
gagner du temps parce que moi ça a pris
un peu de temps et donc je voudrais vous
proposer là tout de suite un petit
exercice vous êtes d'accord
alors installez vous confortablement
dans votre fauteuil
voilà petit moment de détente et vous
allez pouvoir étudier découvrir avec
passion ce qu'il y a dans votre tête et
dans votre corps fermez les yeux
maintenant
concentrez-vous tout d'abord sur le
contact du corps sur votre votre
fauteuil prenez conscience que vous êtes
là assis dans cette pièce à cette
heure-ci de la journée ça c'est
l'instant présent on est où là tout de
suite
et puis vous allez pouvoir partir un
petit peu en exploration devenir les
indiana jones de votre mental et pour
vous aider
je vais vous guider par rapport aux
formes que peut prendre les pensées que
peuvent prendre les pensées vous pouvez
peut-être à voir maintenant dépenser
sous forme d'image comme un film qui
déroule à l'intérieur de soi ou des
flashs de lumière ou bien parfois c'est
un souvenir de l'endroit dans lequel on
est ou de la personne qui est en train
de parler en ce moment ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle les images mentales visuel et
pour d'autres personnes
ça peut être des sons et notamment ce
qu'on appelle la petite voix dans la
tête alors c'est là des fois elle est
très très bavarde
c'est une petite voix qui commentent qui
racontent qu'ils analysent tu dis des
bouts de phrases et puis des fois aussi
qui chante à l'intérieur
la petite voix dans la tête c'est le
dialogue intérieur ya quoi dans vos
têtes
des images
une voix une petite voix intérieure et
la troisième forme celle là on l'appelle
le kinesthésique c'est en fait tout le
domaine des sensations qu'on a dans le
corps c'est à dire le chaud le froid le
contact du du fauteuil par exemple le
lourd
le léger mais aussi dans cette catégorie
à tout le domaine des émotions qu'on
ressent dans le corps la joie la colère
la tristesse tout ça trois formes
possibles de penser dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir ouvrir les yeux et vous en
saurez plus sur votre fonctionnement
intérieur est ce que vous êtes davantage
dans les images dans la petite voix dans
la tête ou dans les émotions le ressenti
corporelle etc voilà alors c'est très
agréable mais vous allez pouvoir ouvrir
les yeux maintenant avec une nouvelle
connaissance sur vous déjà première
étape et c'est intéressant de savoir ça
parce que du coup on peut mieux observer
comment on fonctionne donc chacun
d'entre vous peut déjà le faire dans la
journée à n'importe quel moment
et puis il ya eu le troisième événement
marquant le troisième enseignement alors
celui-là j'ai vraiment découvert par
hasard j'ai appelé le périscope vous
allez voir pourquoi juste après
celui-là je les ai découvert un peu plus
tôt déjà en 2003 en 2003 à l'époque se
donnait encore des concerts de chanson
française pour des américains devant des
publics y avait à chaque fois 100 150
200 personnes et puis lors du premier
concert voilà j'arrive sur scène comme
ça comme ce soir en fait mais j'avais
pas les mêmes abine la même coupe
et puis je commence à chanter ce
répertoire est là le traquent les jambes
qui flageolent le coeur qui bat dix
mille le tout les tous les symptômes du
trac qui apparaissent comme ça à
l'époque
heureusement je pratiquais déjà beaucoup
la méditation et en même temps que tout
ça se manifeste
il ya une forme de conscience
d'observation qui s'installe de façon
tout à fait spontané automatique
c'est à dire que je chante je ressens le
trac à l'intérieur du corps quelques
symptômes comme ça et en même temps il
ya une conscience qui permet que je
garde la tête hors de l'eau
ma tête est libre et du coup je peux
continuer mon concert alors imaginez je
suis là je commence à chanter j'ai le
trac cantier me prend dans ses bras qui
me parle tout bas je vois la vie en rose
et au même moment sa observe on dit ça
ça c'est la conscience témoins
conscience d'observation ca observent
l'émotion et en même temps que c'est
observer et ça c'est magique
l'émotion elle décroît il suffit juste
de l'observer pour que peu à peu les
émotions désagréables apparaissent et
disparaissent naturellement comme ceux
dont je vous parlais au début
voilà ça j'ai appelé ça le périscope
alors pourquoi pas ce que vous
connaissez le périscope c'est l'espèce
de tiges qui a au dessus des sous marins
qui peut se lever un petit peu comme ça
hors de l'eau comme un canard pour
observer le paysage et cette forme de
conscience on est à la fois dans l'eau
et à l'extérieur de l'eau on à la fois
associés et dissociée de l'expérience à
la fois à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
ce qui veut dire que quand même on est
très vivant on ressent complètement les
choses qu'on veut pas devenir des robots
comme ça mais on a la tête libre et un
profond soulagement à l'intérieur de soi
c'était le troisième événement marquant
de ces dernières années donc le premier
les émotions apparaissent et
disparaissent naturellement le deuxième
on a la possibilité de connaître soi
même la forme que prennent nos pensées
et nos émotions visuel auditif la petite
voix dans la tête ou kinesthésique les
ressentis du corps et la troisième il
est possible de découvrir cette
merveilleuse conscience d'observation
conscience témoin qui permettent d'être
tout à fait présent aux choses est
complètement libre
c'est chouette non
ah c'est pas fini parce que pour
terminer j'ai envie de vous proposer un
petit rituel pour la journée un petit
rituel du matin plutôt parce que le
matin c'est un moment clé de notre
journée qui va vous permettre d'intégrer
voir d'incarner complètement ces trois
choses en exercice ça vous dit alors
imaginez vous le matin le réveil sonne
ok alors là généralement on met la
fonction répétition une fois deux fois
et un moment donné faut se lever à ce
moment là ce que je vous propose
soit vous êtes allongé soit vous vous
mettez déjà sur le bord du lit ce que je
vous propose qui peut changer vos vies
c'est de prendre conscience de votre
première pensée du matin juste ça est ce
que c'est une image est ce que c'est une
petite voix dans la tête
est ce que c'est une émotion une
sensation dans le corps puis de la
deuxième et de la troisième
à ce moment là naturellement vous allez
comme ça
changer votre mode habituel devenir
conscient de ce petit ronron de ce petit
moulin qu'on a dans la tête et ce qui
est merveilleux c'est qu'à ce moment là
on se lève non plus comme des robots et
puis on se dirige vers la machine à café
et puis on n'est pas encore vraiment
bien réveiller non on se lève en pleine
conscience en retrouvant à l'intérieur
de soi une liberté plus comme des robots
mais vraiment acteur de son quotidien
ça ça procure je vous le garantis un
grand soulagement à l'intérieur et là on
sait que dans notre journée qui suit
dans la journée qui suit tout est
possible
[Applaudissements]